this show gave me something I didn't
know I needed Jennifer Garner on
mushrooms oh my gosh
and then realizing that like you gotta
commit you gotta do it I haven't seen
the episode
um it it was terrifying to think that I
had to anytime I have to play
inebriated or on any any altering
anything it's terrifying to me I don't
have a lot of things experience
but um Ken Marino really held my hand he
was an amazing director he really he
really made me feel as good as one could
feel when they are standing on their
head I mean I'll admit you know because
I was like obviously these guys would
know each other they're comedy Legends I
expected them to go full bore and when I
saw you do it as well I was like that's
really funny it was really good yeah
okay
you committed to this party down okay
good you're committed to the silliness
and I appreciate it thank you I mean
what was the appeal to doing the show
for you it's the first the first show in
a long time legends this is a group of
Legends who are there's no one funnier
there is no
um there's no writing that is better
it's more sparkly more naughty more more
fun I could not I couldn't jump at it
fast enough honestly I was so so excited
to be invited yeah back in the day
pre-alias I read that you were a hostess
at a restaurant in New York that's true
many and I guess Elizabeth Banks was the
was a Hostess there at some point as
well did you have celebrity run-ins at
the time and then
did you ever like see anybody that you
knew from the restaurant but then you
were Jennifer Garner on set who is that
person oh
oh I mean I remember seeing Steve Martin
somewhere and he was like
figure out where we worked together and
I was like Isabella's you like table
five
um you would come in for lunch that was
me your Hostess he was like wait a
minute no way so yeah I have had that
happen a few times did you have anybody
who was like I'm so glad I was nice to
you yes Conan O'Brien was really always
nice to me and I was able to tell him
and he was like thank goodness yeah
anybody want to throw under the bus for
being a less than generous Tipper I I
was a Hostess so I didn't I wasn't
tipped oh look so if this seat comes
back from I haven't seen the very last
episode of this if this comes back for a
fourth season are you in would you do it
would you did you have enough fun that
you'd be a part of the party down family
going forward we'll have to
have to we'll just have to see
[Music]
thank you